especially with the Carnation like every
other day we record our show a day ahead
of time and it's like Jesus I can't even
[ __ ] we can't even keep up with all
the wild [ __ ] happens speaking of that
you own white lives of matter
indeed yeah so uh so for people who
don't know so this is the other part I
was going to tell you you technically
own the term White lives matter right
the trademark that's a federal trademark
that applies to the whole United States
of America so yeah if you were to go and
and look it up it's owned by Civic
Cipher LLC we acquired the trademark
from an individual in uh our orbit
um who procured that and then also filed
for all lives matter uh federally
because they weren't trademarked right
funnily enough and uh so this person did
that and wanted to ensure that the right
people would benefit from those you know
sayings and we ultimately ended up
acquiring it through our lawyer Morris
um so now we are the deciders of who
profits from those terms uh White lives
matter and all lives matter so if you
ever see any individual selling that
shirt it's either illegal or they have
had to come down our street and knock on
our door and we had to negotiate the
terms of that cell so when are you suing
Kanye West uh well if Kanye West or any
other person decides to sell because he
hasn't sold anything has he hasn't sold
those yet right he decides to sell
something
um you know he will either have to get
clearance or he has to face our
trademark attorney because I saw he was
just giving away the shirts and uh Skid
Row he was just passing him out the
homeless people and then that's that's
totally fine but in terms of profiting
off of a statement that
is intended to dilute the
um significance and the thrust of a
statement as affirming as black lives
matter
um the right people should decide who
who gets money off of that who gets
money off of that exactly if you wanted
to affirm for yourself that white lives
matter in your own
path through life that is your right you
can make you can paint it on your shirt
no one can stop you but if you as soon
as you want to sell it you are
infringing on Civic Cipher llc's
federally protected trademark and you
will be sued wow yes any any longer you
can look it up any lawsuits yet no no we
just send out cease and desists to
people that were selling bootleg
versions of that stuff oh I didn't send
them out the lawyers did we know we're
not lawyers somebody said it was selling
fake White lives matter shirts oh yeah
yeah yeah people sell and and then the
awesome doesn't matter too once that
comes back you know the cnds go out and
then you know if if you ever do see a
person selling them again they came and
they knocked on our door
we choose to donate that to certain
organizations or whatever then that is
our right and we can decide how that
money gets spent and hopefully it'll be
for the betterment of the community's
most impacted by folks like most likely
to wear those those shirts so um you
know there's your Catch-22 we learned
from Byron Allen that you you want to
own the game not the game piece and so
uh and just again some some fortunate
sequence of events took place and we
ended up with
sort of the hot topic of the day this
white lives matter thing and you know
you can you look it up yourself you'll
see Civic Cipher Studios the address
everything is all there